Hosting provided by Host Tornado. They offer website hosting packages, dedicated servers, and VPS solutions. HostT.net. Programming Throwdown, Episode 44, Logo Scratch Lego. Take it away, Patrick. I need to have an answer to
本节目由 Host Tornado 提供。他们提供网站托管套餐、专用服务器和 VPS 解决方案。HostT.net。Programming Throwdown，第 44 期，Logo Scratch Lego。Patrick，开始吧。我需要回答一个问题：
how many monitors should i have at work how many um monitors does it take to get to the center of a problem so i feel like i need more right now i have or maybe i need bigger monitors oh maybe that's the difference the size of the monitor or the number of the monitors so what do do you have right now? So right now I have two 24-inch monitors. Okay. And like side-by-side, and I have them on like adjustable arms, and I have them both in landscape mode. Okay, right.
我在工作中应该用几个显示器？到底需要多少个显示器才能触及问题的核心？我觉得我现在需要更多，或者我可能需要更大的显示器。也许这就是区别所在，是显示器的尺寸还是显示器的数量？你现在用的是什么？我现在有两个 24 英寸的显示器。好的。它们并排摆放，我用的是可调节支架，而且都是横屏模式。好的，明白了。
And so that's pretty good because the way I have it set up is like, so I run Ubuntu, so I have like the virtual desktop side-by-side. I only use two. And on the first one i have like email and like docs and stuff you know kind of on two windows so i can have my email up all the time when i'm on that window or whatever and the second one i typically have like a browser in one window documentation console command line and then the other one my ide um so you do this so the second monitor is like a split screen and the first one's just email or something like that so well so like on my second virtual
这很不错，因为我的设置方式是这样的：我运行 Ubuntu，所以我并排使用虚拟桌面。我只用两个。第一个显示器上我放邮件、文档之类的东西，我把它们分成两个窗口，这样当我使用那个窗口时，邮件可以一直显示。第二个显示器我通常在一个窗口放浏览器、文档、控制台命令行，另一个窗口放我的 IDE。所以你是这样做的，第二个显示器是分屏，第一个只是放邮件之类的？嗯，在我的第二个虚拟
environment yeah the first one the left side is like eclipse and then the second one is like my command line or like documentation in the browser or whatever gotcha so i have two but then yeah like you pointed out now i don't have space for my email and so maybe that's good because i i don't look at my email but i feel like i need four monitors like i feel like i need two more up above for like you know so i can have like my console in one my uh web browser that's like doing documentation the other and my email in the fourth so i feel like but maybe i could just get a bigger one like some people have the 30 inchinch monitors at work. Yeah, right. But then I feel like it's too, like the tall is wasted. Like I don't need really that height.
环境里，左边是 Eclipse，右边是命令行或者浏览器里的文档之类的。明白了。所以我有两个，但正如你所指出的，现在我没有空间放邮件了。也许这很好，因为我不怎么看邮件。但我感觉我需要四个显示器，我感觉上面还需要两个，这样我就可以把控制台放在一个，把查文档的浏览器放在另一个，把邮件放在第四个。但我也可以只买一个更大的，比如有些人工作中用 30 英寸的显示器。是的，没错。但我感觉那样太高了，有点浪费。我并不真的需要那么高。
See, I feel like this is one of those like thing that sort of bifurcates people. Like some people are zero inbox people. Some people have like 40,000 unread messages, right? That would be me. I'm actually a zero inbox person. So some people are like like you know it's like some people like skittle some people like m&ms i don't know whatever but this is one of those things like i only have one monitor and everybody kind of like that gives
你看，我觉得这属于那种让人们产生分歧的事情。有些人是“收件箱清零”派，有些人有 4 万封未读邮件，对吧？那可能就是我。我其实是“收件箱清零”派。所以有些人就像……你知道，就像有些人喜欢彩虹糖，有些人喜欢 M&M 巧克力豆，我不知道，随便吧。但这属于那种情况：我只有一个显示器，每个人都因此
me a hard time but like every now and then someone says hey why don't you get a second monitor or hey you know you have your laptop screen you just have a picture of your family on it and I just for some reason I cannot adopt more than one screen into my workflow even like those virtual screens I've started to get into the virtual screens where like on the MacBook Pro you can use three fingers and swipe if you do the three finger swipe then you go to other virtual screens and i've started doing like my you know music like i'll have twitch streaming streaming music on one virtual screen but even that it's like i i did it for a week and now i'm out of it again yeah so is your you have a big monitor or just a normal monitor i have a it's a big monitor it's probably like a 30 inch it's one of these thunderbolt displays oh so it's like a 4k or 5k
给我找麻烦。但偶尔有人会说：“嘿，你为什么不弄个双显示器？”或者“嘿，你的笔记本屏幕上只放了一张家人的照片。”出于某种原因，我无法在工作流中采用超过一个屏幕。即使是那些虚拟屏幕，我也尝试过。在 MacBook Pro 上，你可以用三根手指滑动，如果你用三指滑动，就可以切换到其他虚拟屏幕。我开始尝试把音乐放在一个虚拟屏幕上，比如在 Twitch 上播放音乐，但即使这样，我也只坚持了一周，然后又放弃了。所以你用的是大显示器还是普通显示器？我用的是大显示器，大概 30 英寸，是那种 Thunderbolt 显示器。哦，那是 4K 或 5K
or something something like that okay i think that makes a difference too i don't have any high resolution ones so oh i see yeah i just yeah i don't know uh i had two monitors at my last job and uh i only ended up using one The other one was just always just... So the thing I think might solve my problem, but I can never get into it, is getting an alternative window manager. So a lot of people use various... What's the Haskell-based one? I always forget. Why is it slipping my mind?
之类的吧？好的，我想这也有区别。我没有任何高分辨率的显示器。哦，我明白了。我不知道，我上一份工作有两个显示器，但我最终只用了一个。另一个总是……我觉得能解决我问题的办法，但我一直没能上手，就是使用替代的窗口管理器。很多人使用各种……那个基于 Haskell 的叫什么来着？我总是忘记。为什么我想不起来了？
Anyways, the tiling window managers where you push buttons and you flip your consoles up to corner, your ID over to the left, and it kind of like resizes them automatically based on their positioning. And whenever they show me, it's like, wow, that's really cool. And then I try to use their computer. I'm like helping them with something. I'm like, I can't make it do anything. And then it's like if you only ever use one one computer i guess it's good but for me the
总之，就是那种平铺式窗口管理器，你按下按钮，就能把控制台推到角落，把 IDE 推到左边，它会根据位置自动调整大小。每当他们向我展示时，我都觉得：“哇，那太酷了。”然后我试着使用他们的电脑，比如帮他们处理点什么，我就觉得：“我什么都做不了。”如果只用一台电脑，这可能很好，但对我来说，
context switching is so hard i also same reason i don't have a lot of aliases in my bash script so i have like very minimal aliases because when i sit down at someone else's computer and i start and it's like oh it's not working oh yeah oh because and then i don't know what the command is because i don't type it do you use have you did you switch over to the oh my zsh after we did that show so i i did for my so actually you had baboon was it the same show or a different show yeah yeah so i use that on a windows computer now and uh so yeah i have it on there and i like it except that occasionally it has problems because i get auto updates and then like it did like a bad update once and it took me like an hour just to get back to where i needed and it's like stuff like that just kills me yeah yeah but the oh my
上下文切换太难了。同样的原因，我的 bash 脚本里也没有很多别名，因为我只保留最少的别名。当我坐到别人的电脑前，开始操作时，发现“哦，它没反应”，然后我就不知道命令是什么了，因为我平时不打那个命令。你换到 oh my zsh 了吗？在我们做完那期节目之后。我换了，其实你当时提到了……是同一期节目还是另一期？对，我在 Windows 电脑上也用了它。我喜欢它，除了偶尔会出问题，因为我有自动更新，有一次更新坏了，我花了一个小时才恢复到正常状态。这种事情真的让我很抓狂。是的，但是 oh my
zsh i love the tap completion like i found out the other day it would actually if you're typing a switch like a like a command line argument to a function um it actually has tap completion there so when you hit tab it runs the command with dash dash help. It pulls out all of the switches, and then it tries to complete. It's like super awesome. That's pretty cool. So I saw the people who do stock trading, and then I think they have the answer to how many monitors.
zsh，我喜欢它的 Tab 补全功能。前几天我发现，如果你在输入函数的命令行参数，它竟然也有 Tab 补全。当你按下 Tab 键时，它会运行带有 --help 的命令，提取出所有的开关参数，然后尝试补全。这简直太棒了。那确实很酷。我看到那些做股票交易的人，我想他们有关于“需要多少个显示器”的答案。
Oh, yeah, like 100. Like the 3x3. Yeah, right. Or whatever. So they have like three rows three rows and it looks like you know almost like a surround screen but then i guess you just go to like a vr like oculus rift with like total like immersion in like a sphere of monitor or something there's some guy with the oculus rift right now who's just banking in the stock market i mean he's just every trade is just
哦，是的，比如 100 个。像 3x3 那种。是的，没错。或者别的什么。他们有三行三行，看起来就像环绕屏。但我猜你直接用 VR，比如 Oculus Rift，实现完全沉浸式的球形显示器之类的。现在有个家伙戴着 Oculus Rift 在股市里大赚特赚，每一笔交易都像是
he's pulling the he's pulling the the uh the one-armed bandit and getting a huge jackpot. He is the high-frequency trader. I feel like this is an NBC show coming this fall. Oh, man. Anyway, so I feel like I need, wherever I is, I always need an additional monitor, but then it's almost not always worth it. Some people have a big monitor and a small monitor,
他在拉老虎机，赢得了大奖。他就是高频交易员。我觉得这会是今年秋天 NBC 的一部剧。天哪。总之，我觉得无论我在哪里，我总是需要一个额外的显示器，但通常又不值得。有些人用一个大显示器和一个小显示器，
and that's just jarring to me oh yeah i can't deal with that or some people have the monitor for reading like the monitor for reading the portrait papers yeah that's a portrait and then one yeah i don't know why but that i think i have like sort of like a ocd when it comes to symmetry on monitors but i just cannot i can't even look at the people who have mismatched the same size but like different brands and so the bezels are different colors yeah yeah i can't deal with that oh man i was that kid growing up though who if someone like even if a small corner of the tv screen was blocked by someone's head i would ask them to move like like you could please move your head a little bit you're blocking you know one one thousandth of the tv screen so you don't like
那对我来说太刺眼了。哦，是的，我受不了那个。或者有些人用一个显示器专门阅读，比如竖屏阅读文档。是的，那是竖屏的。我不知道为什么，但我对显示器的对称性有强迫症。我甚至无法直视那些显示器尺寸不匹配，或者品牌不同导致边框颜色不一样的人。是的，我受不了那个。天哪，我小时候就是那种孩子，如果电视屏幕的一小角被别人的头挡住了，我会请他们挪一下，比如“请把头挪开一点，你挡住了电视屏幕的千分之一”。所以你不喜欢
going to movies then okay yeah exactly although the movie they do it right yeah the the projector is stadium seating yeah yeah right um all right so on to news the first article i have is um like i didn't look at the guy's name i think it's andy gavin um making crash bandicoot so crash bandicoot came out for the playstation one as i think one of the launch titles and um this guy uh andy gavin was at naughty dog well i guess it was a very new company at the time i think they had made one or two games anyways and he has a series that i saw linked to off of reddit or something of like 13 series about writing him and the other guy who were kind of like the head people at naughty dog um making crash bandicoot and how that like people at the time were just like i remember
去电影院看电影吗？好吧，确实。虽然电影院做得很好，投影仪是阶梯式座位。好的，那么进入新闻环节。我看到的第一篇文章是……我没看作者的名字，我想是 Andy Gavin，关于制作《古惑狼》。《古惑狼》是作为 PlayStation 1 的首发游戏之一推出的。这个叫 Andy Gavin 的人在顽皮狗（Naughty Dog），当时那还是个非常新的公司，我想他们当时只做了一两款游戏。总之，他有一个系列文章，我是在 Reddit 上看到的，大概有 13 篇，讲的是他和另一个负责人如何制作《古惑狼》。当时人们……我记得
playing crash bandicoot did you play crash bandicoot i never played it but oh okay so like at the time i was a little younger i guess so i didn't really realize it was the new playstation right like i just thought this was how everything was going to be now um but i guess like at the time it was like one of the very first kind of 3d platformers and um how to do level design how to get all the textures compressed and how to um put things in your field of view that blocked like distant objects so the number of polygons on screen was reduced all that kind of stuff he goes into in this blog and like you know it's kind of funny when you read it he says that you know for doing like saving space after they'd already
玩《古惑狼》的情景。你玩过《古惑狼》吗？我没玩过。哦，好吧。当时我年纪比较小，没意识到那是新的 PlayStation，我以为以后所有的游戏都会是那样。但当时它是最早的 3D 平台游戏之一。关于如何进行关卡设计，如何压缩所有纹理，以及如何在视野中放置物体来遮挡远处的物体，从而减少屏幕上的多边形数量，他在博客里都讲了。读起来挺有趣的，他说为了节省空间，在做了所有显而易见的事情之后，
done all the obvious things like using the lowest two bits of all the pointers to store data it's like the obvious things and then it's like oh okay i know so all the addresses must be four byte aligned then you can use the lowest two bits because they're always zero i saw i saw i think it was a part of this article where they he was saying that they had this monte carlo based approach to compress all of the textures yes and uh yeah they couldn't get it to fit on the cd so they just ran it over and over again until it finally fit yeah they were trying random permutations of like placements of objects hoping to find one that would pack more elegantly yeah it's unbelievable so i guess like but though when it shipped it was like so far ahead of like what other people were doing with the playstation
比如利用所有指针的最低两位来存储数据。这很显而易见，因为所有地址必须是 4 字节对齐的，所以最低两位总是零。我看到这篇文章的一部分，他说他们用了一种基于蒙特卡洛的方法来压缩所有纹理。是的，他们无法让它塞进 CD 里，所以他们一遍又一遍地运行，直到最终塞进去。他们尝试了物体放置的随机排列，希望能找到一种更优雅的打包方式。这简直不可思议。所以当它发布时，它比当时其他人用 PlayStation 做的东西领先太多了，
at the time that it was like a massive achievement so yeah it's amazing but it's just kind of fun to read those crazy hacks that people did uh you can also read like john carmack writes about them sometimes and i mean a lot of times they're actually still even useful but you know there are things you should never do unless you really absolutely have to but it's still kind of fun to read about them yeah i saw this um i did a little bit of work on ogre that open source graphics engine and uh i was just you know flipping through that code one time a while back and it said uh it basically it had this square root function that was done using like a division or something like that convert to float and then using uh like a two iteration newton solver yeah this is a famous john carmack hack yeah yeah and it had a reference to like some article john carmack wrote and
这是一个巨大的成就。这太神奇了，读读那些疯狂的黑客技巧很有趣。你也可以读读 John Carmack 有时写的文章，很多时候它们甚至仍然有用。当然，有些事情除非万不得已，否则永远不要做，但了解一下还是很有趣的。我之前在 Ogre（那个开源图形引擎）上做过一点工作，有一次我翻看代码，发现它有一个平方根函数，是用除法之类的实现的，转换成浮点数，然后用两次迭代的牛顿法求解。这就是著名的 John Carmack 黑客技巧。是的，它还引用了 John Carmack 写的一篇文章，
everything i was like this is amazing yeah i have i have some code that has that hack in it oh nice so it's not it's not a hack it's just like a very fast way of doing a square root. Yeah, it's a fast approximation of a square root. Yeah, so Apple will open source Swift. We did a show on Swift. That was back when there was Swift 1.0, another Swift 2.0, which is not backwards compatible, but has a lot of extra features and things like that.
一切都太神奇了。我有一些代码里就有那个技巧。哦，不错。所以那不是黑客行为，那只是一种计算平方根的非常快的方法。是的，它是平方根的快速近似值。好的，苹果开源了 Swift。我们做过一期关于 Swift 的节目。那是 Swift 1.0 的时候，后来有了 Swift 2.0，它不向后兼容，但有很多额外的功能。
And Apple open sourced it which is pretty cool because that sort of people are wondering if Swift will be the next sort of C sharp where C sharp was kind of like contested territory and mono came out at the beginning Microsoft wasn't really supporting mono now they are but it's kind of too late and the whole thing kind of like is very ugly. And so we were wondering sort of what's going to happen with Swift. There's already a variety of open source projects that are trying to do various things with Swift.
苹果开源了它，这很酷，因为人们在想 Swift 是否会成为下一个 C#。C# 当时是争议地带，Mono 刚出来时，微软并没有真正支持它，现在支持了，但已经太晚了，整个事情看起来很丑陋。所以我们想知道 Swift 会发生什么。已经有各种开源项目试图用 Swift 做各种事情。
And Apple decided to just open source their implementation of Swift, which I believe boils down to like a Swift to LLVM compiler, kind of like Clang. So, but I don't know too much about the details. So that was announced at WWDC, which happened since our last episode. Yep. So lots of Apple news came out. so now i i guess also there was recently rulings about the google verse oracle api uh for java stuff but i always feel like when someone doesn't open source the language i guess it's what what is the name his name starts with i the guy who did mono um oh i don't know i'll look it up miguel's i something anyways um but he did Mono and implemented C Sharp, but basically a different compiler runtime thing for Linux.
苹果决定开源他们的 Swift 实现，我相信这归结为 Swift 到 LLVM 的编译器，有点像 Clang。但我不太了解细节。这是在 WWDC 上宣布的，那是在我们上一期节目之后发生的。是的，所以有很多苹果的新闻。现在，我想最近还有关于 Google 对 Oracle API 的 Java 诉讼的裁决。但我总觉得，当有人不开源某种语言时……那个做 Mono 的人叫什么来着？名字以 I 开头……哦，我不知道，我会查一下，Miguel 什么的。总之，他做了 Mono 并实现了 C#，基本上是 Linux 上的一个不同的编译器运行时。
And I feel like similar to what Android uses with a non-Sun or Oracle implementation of Java to run on Android, you can almost, these languages being open source can be vague in what they mean i almost feel like people have the opportunity to implement them but now it seems like maybe that's not always going to be so legal so it's good to hear that apple is going to open source it so people who want to be able to write a version of the front end for other systems will have the ability to do so yep the guy's name is miguel de y casa
我觉得这类似于 Android 使用非 Sun 或 Oracle 的 Java 实现来在 Android 上运行。这些语言开源的含义可能很模糊，我感觉人们有机会实现它们，但现在看来这可能并不总是合法的。所以很高兴听到苹果要开源 Swift，这样想要为其他系统编写前端版本的人就有能力这样做了。是的，那个人叫 Miguel de Icaza。
yeah okay and uh he also co-founded gnome which is pretty awesome um uh he worked at novelle which is pretty cool um well good i'm glad i wasn't completely off because i had like his name i could see it in my head and then i was like oh i was gonna say ig something but i seem akaza okay yeah yeah all right so so yeah so i don't know is it legal though or maybe it changed now it's like if someone has a language that doesn't have an open source in any way can you use the uh the grammar of the language like is the grammar copyrighted um well that's what that lawsuit is about right it's it's is the well specifically the apis of the standard library or something yeah right so yeah i mean you know that's right we're not lawyers i don't know
是的，他还共同创立了 GNOME，这很棒。他在 Novell 工作过，也很酷。好吧，我很高兴我没完全记错，因为我脑子里有他的名字，我本来想说 Ig 什么的，但原来是 Icaza。好的。好吧，那么……我不知道这是否合法，或者现在变了？如果有人拥有一种没有任何开源方式的语言，你可以使用该语言的语法吗？语法有版权吗？嗯，这就是那场诉讼的内容，对吧？是关于标准库的 API 之类的。是的，没错。我们不是律师，我不知道。
actually well the last i heard about that lawsuit just to report on it again. Yeah, we're not taking a stance here or anything, but I believe Google asked the president to bring it up with the Supreme Court and the president said no. The president's staff said no. And so... Yeah, I think just this week or last week, the Supreme Court basically said they weren't going to hear it.
其实，关于那场诉讼，我最后听到的消息是……我们再报道一下。是的，我们不持立场，但我相信 Google 请求总统将其提交给最高法院，总统拒绝了。总统的幕僚拒绝了。所以……是的，我想就在这周或上周，最高法院基本上表示他们不会审理此案。
So yeah, it's just going to stay with the last appeal, which was in favor of Oracle. Right, right right so i guess actually what does that mean just mechanically like does that mean that google has to pay oracle a dollar for every android phone or something or i mean i mean i think that'll go like that'll be decided like in the penalties phase or something oh i see okay now i i'm curious what the implications of the um actual ruling will be yeah right i mean how do you enforce that considering you know it's been going on and everything it seems complicated yeah it is it's pretty wild um so yeah we had wwdc we also had e3 yes all the video gamers out there in podcast
所以它将维持上一次的上诉结果，即支持 Oracle。没错。那么这在机制上意味着什么？这意味着 Google 必须为每部 Android 手机向 Oracle 支付一美元吗？或者……我想这会在处罚阶段决定。哦，我明白了。我现在很好奇实际裁决的影响会是什么。是的，考虑到它已经持续了这么久，这似乎很复杂。确实，这很疯狂。所以我们有 WWDC，还有 E3。是的，所有播客里的游戏玩家们。
so cool did you watch any of it uh i watched some of the highlight videos okay so i watched some about the oculus rift yeah that's the only one i saw i saw somebody playing minecraft like on a table with the oculus no that was with the holo lens oh sorry sorry you're right you're right how can you mix those up yeah you're totally right i'm an idiot but yeah i saw someone playing minecraft like on their on some regular coffee table with the holo lens and that looked freaking amazing uh so they had the oculus rift was there too and they have some cool motion controllers um which people always say it's kind of awkward like a lot of the stuff now you still use your keyboard and so it's kind of uh not the most natural but they're coming out with some controllers and i i kind of want to try an
太酷了，你看直播了吗？我看了些精彩片段。我看了关于 Oculus Rift 的，那是唯一一个我看到的。我看到有人用 Oculus 在桌子上玩《我的世界》，不，那是 HoloLens。哦，抱歉，你是对的。我怎么会搞混？你是对的，我是个白痴。但我看到有人用 HoloLens 在普通的咖啡桌上玩《我的世界》，那看起来太棒了。他们也有 Oculus Rift，还有一些很酷的运动控制器。人们总是说它有点笨拙，因为很多东西你现在仍然要用键盘，所以它不是最自然的。但他们要推出一些控制器，我有点想尝试一下
oculus rift i've just never had the opportunity to try one yet but i feel like i wouldn't be something i would be super into but but i want to try it i think it would be cool and you know what got me into it like i saw a ton of videos on oculus i saw i followed it since the kickstarter but it always seemed like you said like something i wouldn't um be interested in and then i saw somebody recreated um the first legend of zelda using the oculus and so it's by recreated i mean it uses the exact same artwork and everything like that and the level layout is the same and the missions are all the same but it's first person using
Oculus Rift。我还没机会试过，但我感觉那可能不是我特别感兴趣的东西，但我还是想试。我觉得那会很酷。你知道是什么让我感兴趣吗？我看了很多关于 Oculus 的视频，从 Kickstarter 开始我就关注它，但它一直看起来像你说的那样，是我不感兴趣的东西。然后我看到有人用 Oculus 重制了第一代《塞尔达传说》。重制的意思是它使用了完全相同的艺术风格，关卡布局和任务也一样，但它是第一人称视角，使用
oculus and it looked pretty wild i mean someone you know kind of goes around a pillar and a skeleton's there and it's just like it's very jarring it took a very benign game and made it like extremely terrifying oh man yeah i mean now that it's getting what would that be first party support third party support whatever now that it's getting like you know a lot of games are going to start using it um or have it as an option i guess maybe it'll be make more sense in my head but it has like a lot of tech demos is what it seemed like to me like a lot of short little games people are putting out to kind of test out the technology but it's not quite there yet so i'm really interested in it but i think i'm more interested in like the version
Oculus，看起来非常狂野。有人绕过一根柱子，骷髅就在那里，这非常刺眼。它把一个非常温和的游戏变得极其恐怖。天哪。是的，现在它有了第一方或第三方支持，随着很多游戏开始使用它，或者把它作为一个选项，也许它在我脑海里会更有意义。但它目前看起来有很多技术演示，人们发布了很多短小的游戏来测试这项技术，但它还没完全成熟。所以我对它很感兴趣，但我更感兴趣的是所有这些头显的
two of all these headsets yeah right so someone made oculus run minecraft um which i guess is the same as hololens but but uh but that was a while ago, like a year or two ago. It was pretty cool. But I guess then now it'll solve this problem that the Wii U tried to solve with the tablet for per person or whatever, or using other game controllers. So if everyone's wearing an Oculus Rift, you can play like Madden, and no one can see what plays you're picking or like... Oh, yeah, true.
第二代产品。是的，没错。有人让 Oculus 运行《我的世界》，这和 HoloLens 是一样的，但那是很久以前的事了，一两年前。那很酷。但我猜它现在可以解决 Wii U 试图用平板电脑解决的问题，或者使用其他游戏控制器。如果每个人都戴着 Oculus Rift，你可以玩像《麦登橄榄球》这样的游戏，没人能看到你选了什么战术……哦，是的，没错。
So you'll all sit on the couch playing games together, not being able to see each other. That's what all the teenagers, teenagers will do okay so also i saw the video which i don't know if you've seen the actual gameplay video for star wars battlefront and i'm not a big online gamer like i mostly just play by myself because i'm not friends i know it's sad well for i mean anyone who has kids pretty much needs a pause button otherwise okay, it's the game. Okay, fair point. I was being self-deprecating. But the Star Wars battlefront was really, really cool. So I'm getting very excited about the new Star Wars movies. And I feel like I shouldn't, but I am. Oh, really?
所以你们可以坐在沙发上一起玩游戏，却看不到对方。这就是青少年们会做的事。好的，我还看到了视频，我不知道你有没有看过《星球大战：前线》的实际游戏视频。我不是一个大型在线游戏玩家，我大多只是自己玩，因为我没有朋友。我知道这很可悲。好吧，对于任何有孩子的人来说，基本上都需要一个暂停键，否则……好吧，这是游戏。好的，有道理。我刚才是在自嘲。但《星球大战：前线》真的很酷。所以我对新的《星球大战》电影感到非常兴奋。我觉得我不应该这样，但我确实很兴奋。哦，真的吗？
Okay, I wouldn't go that far. Okay, now you're self-deprecating. Wait, what? I'm just kidding. Okay, anyways. I just like the last one. Anyways, you know, I know i was again i was a little younger than some people well that's we're done anyways when the second set of star wars
好吧，我不会走那么远。好吧，现在你在自嘲了。等等，什么？我开玩笑的。好吧，总之。我只是喜欢上一部。总之，你知道，我再次重申，我比某些人年轻一点。好吧，当第二套《星球大战》
movies came out so like jar jar binks when i went to see the movie i was still of an age where it wasn't so appalling to me and uh so i actually have fond memories of even the second set of movies i remember i mean i actually don't remember much even the second set of movies. I remember. I mean, I actually don't remember much about the second set of movies, which is kind of a shame. But I do remember there was that one part in the first one where they were using some kind of submarine and a giant fish starts chasing them. And then an even bigger fish eats that fish. That was pretty cool. But, yeah, for some reason, not to jump on the bandwagon here, but the second trilogy just didn't resonate at all with me.
电影出来时，比如贾贾·宾克斯，我去看电影时正处于一个不觉得它那么糟糕的年纪。所以我对第二套电影甚至有美好的回忆。我记得……其实我不记得第二套电影的太多内容了。我记得……其实我不记得第二套电影的太多内容了，这有点遗憾。但我确实记得第一部里有一部分，他们用某种潜水艇，一条巨大的鱼开始追他们。然后一条更大的鱼吃了那条鱼。那很酷。但是，是的，出于某种原因，不是要随大流，但第二部三部曲对我来说完全没有共鸣。
I didn't think they were bad, but I remember absolutely nothing. But the first trilogy I remember very vividly. So also Fallout 4. Yep. People seem to be really excited about this at work. Everyone wants to talk about this. But I'm one of the few people
我不觉得它们很烂，但我什么都不记得了。但我对第一部三部曲记忆犹新。还有《辐射 4》。是的。工作中大家似乎对此非常兴奋。每个人都想谈论这个。但我属于少数人之一，
who I couldn't really get into Fallout 3. I tried i tried and it was just maybe it's because of kids or whatever like i just couldn't get into it and like did you play melee or did you use a gun i don't even think i made it far enough i made it like two or three hours in and i get just like too much reading of text and uh or or i guess there's not text but um but dialogue the dialogue yeah just uh anyways see i played it the first time and i i had a pistol and i kind of did what i think is the you know a normal person would do who knows nothing about the game just kind of going through it and it was kind of boring and then uh i got like i learned about vats where you kind of go into this
我真的无法沉浸在《辐射 3》中。我试过，我试过，也许是因为孩子或者其他什么原因，我就是无法沉浸其中。你玩的是近战还是用枪？我甚至不觉得我玩得够久。我玩了两三个小时，觉得读的文字太多了，或者……我猜不是文字，是对话。对话，是的，只是……总之，你看，我第一次玩的时候，我有一把手枪，我做了我认为一个对游戏一无所知的人会做的正常事情，只是通关，这有点无聊。然后我了解了 VATS，你可以进入这个……
did you get that far to where you had VATS? no VATS is basically it turns a game into kind of like a turn based game basically it freezes time and then you get a couple of bonus attacks
你玩到有 VATS 的地方了吗？没有。VATS 基本上把游戏变成了一种回合制游戏，它会冻结时间，然后你获得几次额外攻击。
kind of think of it that way whether they hit or not isn't based on your FPS skills, but it's based on just like some calculations based on your stats and things like that. And so I got the Bloody Mess perk, which makes every time you kill someone they just get like horrifically mangled. And then I used a sledgehammer and I used this VATS thing and it was just so fun. The game went from like just okay to extremely fun just knocking people's heads off with the hammer maybe i'll bust out my
可以这样想，它们是否命中不基于你的 FPS 技巧，而是基于你属性的计算。我获得了“血腥乱舞”特权，这使得每次你杀死某人时，他们都会被极其残忍地肢解。然后我用了大锤和 VATS 系统，这太有趣了。游戏从“还可以”变成了“极其有趣”，用锤子敲掉人们的头。也许我会重新拿出
fallout 3 and try again because people seem to like at work they were saying how many times they've played it through and get like all the achievements and yeah yeah definitely go melee it's it's pretty fun okay i'll maybe i it another go. But then the other thing I'm really excited for is Final Fantasy VII coming out on iOS. Yes. It has been said that it's coming out this year. And I remember playing through Final Fantasy VII, and I got pretty far before my brother pulled the save card out while I was saving or something and corrupted my game. I don't remember.
《辐射 3》再试一次，因为工作中大家都在说他们通关了多少次，拿到了所有成就。是的，一定要玩近战，非常有趣。好的，也许我会再试一次。但我真正兴奋的另一件事是《最终幻想 7》要在 iOS 上发布了。是的。据说今年会发布。我记得我玩过《最终幻想 7》，在我弟弟在我保存时拔掉记忆卡导致游戏损坏之前，我玩得相当远了。我不记得了。
I think there was three or four discs, and I was on disc three or two or three. And then I was so disheartened I didn't play it anymore oh man that happened to me on some games um but yeah that that feeling it kind of like and then it gives you sort of like a vengeance you know like now it's like you have to get redemption for that event well and this is your chance uh anyways so i but i will i'm excited to play it on ios yeah super cool i i think they're gonna bump up the graphics things like that so yeah i don't even like i guess i don't even care maybe if i saw it i'd be like oh wow this is actually really bad but um yeah you'd be surprised nostalgia i just want the nostalgia all right fair enough um but yeah it was totally awesome.
我想有三四张盘，我玩到了第二或第三张盘。然后我太灰心了，就没再玩了。天哪，有些游戏我也遇到过这种情况。但那种感觉……它给了你一种复仇感，你知道，现在你必须为那件事赎罪。好吧，这是你的机会。总之，我很兴奋能在 iOS 上玩它。是的，超级酷。我想他们会提升图形效果之类的。所以，是的，我甚至不在乎，也许如果我看到了，我会说“哦，哇，这真的很烂”，但……是的，你会惊讶的，怀旧，我只是想要那种怀旧感。好吧，公平地说。但它确实非常棒。
Did you see the Nintendo World Championship? No. So I didn't know about this, but maybe this happens every year. Maybe it's the first year. I don't know. But someone just kind of said, hey, hey, tune into this while it was happening. And basically, they had this championship to see who was the best Nintendo player. And so they had a person play just a variety of games or segments of games, and it was based on time and score and things like that. They had narrowed it down to two people,
你看任天堂世界锦标赛了吗？没有。我不知道这个，也许每年都有。也许是第一年。我不知道。但有人说：“嘿，调到这个频道看看。”基本上，他们举办了这次锦标赛来选出谁是最好的任天堂玩家。他们让选手玩各种游戏或游戏片段，基于时间和分数之类的。他们把范围缩小到两个人，
and so that's when they announced that Wii U is coming out with Mario Maker, where they took all of the enemies, obstacles, terrain, everything from all of the Mario games, and put it all into one editor. And even some new enemies that never existed. Put it all into one editor and give you crazy control to adjust the size of the enemies, things like that. And then not only did they make that announcement, but they also had these two unfortunate
然后他们宣布 Wii U 将推出《马里奥制造》，他们把所有马里奥游戏中的敌人、障碍、地形、一切都放进了一个编辑器里。甚至还有一些从未存在过的新敌人。把它们都放进一个编辑器，给你疯狂的控制权来调整敌人大小之类的。不仅如此，他们还让这两个不幸的
people play these ridiculously hard levels that these game designers made with Mario Maker and it was pretty awesome. If you haven't seen it definitely check it out. I'll have to go check that out now. Let's pause this while I go do that. Alright.
人玩了这些游戏设计师用《马里奥制造》制作的极其困难的关卡，这太棒了。如果你还没看过，一定要去看看。我现在得暂停一下去看看。好的。
Okay. So next news story is Chirp Distributed file system so um this is pretty cool i i have to look more into it but it does address a serious use case of mine um so you know okay you have a well i have a laptop at work and I have a desktop. And I typically want to use the desktop when I am there at my desk and the laptop the rest of the time. But you constantly run into problems where, oh, I wrote some code on my laptop. I have to just finish it on my laptop. And so what ended up happening is I ended up just never using the desktop.
好的。下一个新闻故事是 Chirp 分布式文件系统。这很酷，我得深入研究一下，但它确实解决了我的一个严重痛点。你知道，我在工作中有台笔记本电脑，还有台台式机。我通常在办公桌前想用台式机，其余时间用笔记本。但你经常遇到问题，比如“哦，我在笔记本上写了一些代码，我必须在笔记本上完成它”。结果就是我最终根本不用台式机了。
Some other people go the other way where they're remote desktoped into their desktop But that always kind of is hokey Remote desktop is never really 100% And it's kind of ugly and things like that So I started using It turns out you can lock down BitTorrent sync So you can set it up to where only if you're in the same class D network Will you do the
有些人走另一条路，远程桌面连接到他们的台式机。但这总是很蹩脚，远程桌面从来没有 100% 完美，而且很丑陋之类的。所以我开始使用……事实证明你可以锁定 BitTorrent Sync。你可以设置它，只有当你处于同一个 C 类网络时才进行
sync. So I locked down the BitTorrent sync and I got it running on both machines and I can literally just build something on my laptop, go to my desktop and it's done. Or do a code change on my desktop, etc. It's cool but it's not really designed for that. There is latency and things like that. So this sounds like it's even better where you have some distributed file system and you could just work off of that. Kind of like an NFS kind of thing. So I don't know too
同步。所以我锁定了 BitTorrent Sync，并在两台机器上运行它。我可以字面上在笔记本上构建东西，走到台式机前，它就完成了。或者在台式机上做代码更改，等等。这很酷，但它不是为此设计的。有延迟之类的。所以这听起来更好，你有一个分布式文件系统，你可以直接在上面工作。有点像 NFS 那种东西。所以我不知道太多
much about it but I'm hoping... Wait, so did you say the name? This is the Chirp distributed file system. Yeah, it's called Chirp uh i'll look more into it and report back but it looks pretty cool all right time for book of the show book of the show this is kind of a cop-out but a ton of people have been asking recommending that i read this in fact i'm going to uh read it with a buddy at work um we're going to do a book club or whatever. I've never done a book club before. Really? I've never done one either.
关于它的细节，但我希望……等等，你说名字了吗？这是 Chirp 分布式文件系统。是的，它叫 Chirp。我会深入研究并回来报告，但它看起来很酷。好的，现在是本期书单时间。这有点偷懒，但很多人一直在推荐我读这本书。事实上，我要和一个同事一起读，我们要搞个读书会之类的。我以前从没参加过读书会。真的吗？我也从没参加过。
This will be the first time. I've done plenty of research paper reading clubs or whatever they're called. Reading groups. I've done plenty of reading groups where you pick a research paper every week and go over it. I've never done a book club until now. Anyways, this book is called Godel Escher Bach.
这将是第一次。我参加过很多研究论文阅读小组。阅读小组。我参加过很多阅读小组，每周选一篇研究论文去讨论。但我从没参加过读书会。总之，这本书叫《哥德尔、艾舍尔、巴赫》。
It's super famous among computer scientists, linguists, things like that. But basically, I'm not going to do it justice because I haven't read it yet. But it's basically about language and about formal automata and formal systems. It kind of like plays games with language, and it has a lot of puzzles in it. But it's not a puzzle book. It's not like this is puzzle number three. It's written as a novel, but it has an incredible amount of information, and it's just a fascinating read.
它在计算机科学家、语言学家中非常有名。但我不会对它进行公正的评价，因为我还没读过。但它基本上是关于语言、形式自动机和形式系统的。它有点像在玩语言游戏，里面有很多谜题。但它不是一本谜题书。它不是那种“这是谜题三”的书。它写得像小说，但包含极其丰富的信息，是一本引人入胜的书。
So I've, I've heard a lot of good things about it. And yeah, I hope to report back next show on how awesome this book is. All right. Yeah. I, I feel like I've picked this book up before a couple of times and then
所以我听过很多关于它的好评。是的，我希望下期节目能回来报告这本书有多棒。好的。是的，我感觉我之前拿起过这本书几次，然后
never made it through. Did you, how far did you get? I don't know. I'm trying to remember now I'm looking like I'm trying to read this like table of contents, but I've read books like the you know people in the book wherever goddle and others like have been covered in other books i've read so i don't know if i'm mixing up like i've read several books about kind of the same same topics or whatever what is it called like popular
从来没读完。你读到哪了？我不知道。我正在努力回忆，我看着目录，但我读过像书中提到的哥德尔和其他人的书，他们被其他书涵盖过。所以我不知道我是不是搞混了，我读过几本关于相同主题的书，或者别的什么。这叫什么来着？流行
math or novel novelized math yeah like um this is like a format is called something and i've read david deutsch has that book um and then uh simon sing also has has books like this and so i've read several of those so i don't know if maybe i'm mixing it up with one of those so i'm looking trying to look up what david deutsch's book is um but but yeah the yeah, The Fabric of Reality, David Deutsch. That's another good book if you're if you like reading about popular math. But just to finish it up,
数学或小说化数学。是的，比如……这种格式叫什么，我读过 David Deutsch 的那本书，还有 Simon Singh 也有这样的书。所以我读过几本，所以我不知道是不是把它和其中一本搞混了。我正在查 David Deutsch 的书叫什么……但是的，是的，《现实的结构》，David Deutsch。如果你喜欢读流行数学，那是另一本好书。但总结一下，
so Godel is a mathematician. Escher is a person who's famous for writing these or for drawing these you know these pencil diagrams, pencil drawings that defy logic.
哥德尔是一位数学家。艾舍尔是一位以绘制这些……绘制这些铅笔图而闻名的人，这些铅笔画挑战逻辑。
There'll be a waterfall that falls in a loop. You've probably seen them. You just might not know that's what they're called. Yeah, right. And then Bach is of course a musician. So I guess
会有循环流动的瀑布。你可能见过它们。你只是可能不知道它们叫什么。是的，没错。巴赫当然是一位音乐家。所以我猜
my vague understanding of this book is that it tries to link all of these things together under the umbrella of formal systems. And yeah, it should be pretty cool. Interesting. So how do you say his name? I always think I said the first guy's name is Goddle. Is that not right?
我对这本书模糊的理解是，它试图在形式系统的框架下将所有这些东西联系起来。是的，它应该很酷。有趣。那么他的名字怎么读？我一直以为第一个人的名字读作 Goddle。不对吗？
I will look it up. Okay. I'm pretty sure it's Godel. Okay. I say a lot of things wrong because a lot of things I read growing up, like I just get books from the library and read them because I was a nerd and am a nerd.
我会查一下。我肯定它是 Godel。好的。我读错了很多东西，因为我小时候读的很多东西都是从图书馆借来的，因为我是个书呆子，现在也是。
And so I never heard them. And then, yeah. I was having this conversation with someone the other day about how I used to say, oh, we were having it on the podcast, I think, about Linux instead of Linux. Yeah. Okay. It's Goodell.
所以我从没听过它们的发音。然后，是的。前几天我和别人谈论这个，关于我过去怎么读，哦，我们在播客上讨论过，关于 Linux 而不是 Linux。好的。是 Goodell。
So I went on Wikipedia and I clicked listen. And it said Goodell. i went on wikipedia and i clicked listen and it said goodell kurt goodell goodell all right yeah well go on to wikipedia and listen to the pronunciation right yeah i mean that's me trying to sound like a german so there you go my book is leviathan wakes which is a science fiction by the what do you call a pseudonym yes pseudonymous yeah or james s a corey which i believe is actually a pseudonym for two authors and um they wrote a book this book uh i found it to be pretty good um it wasn't as good as some of the other science fiction books i wrote but you know i definitely i give it a strong recommendation but not a you must read this like stop whatever else you're reading and read it okay it was it was interesting and it was it wasn't so it's considered hard science
所以我上了维基百科，点击了收听。它说 Goodell。我上了维基百科，点击了收听，它说 Goodell，库尔特·哥德尔，Goodell。好的，是的，去维基百科听听发音吧。是的，那就是我试图听起来像个德国人，所以就这样吧。我的书是《利维坦觉醒》，这是一本科幻小说，作者是……你叫什么笔名？是的，笔名。James S.A. Corey，我相信这实际上是两位作者的笔名。他们写了这本书，我发现它相当不错。它不如我读过的其他一些科幻小说好，但你知道，我绝对强烈推荐它，但不是那种“你必须读这个，放下你正在读的一切去读它”的程度。好的，它很有趣，而且它不是……所以它被认为是硬科幻。
fiction but i didn't find it to be that uh wait what does that mean so i actually i was looking this up the other day what hard science what defines hard science fiction. And I couldn't come up with a good definition. But I think it's just science fiction with an emphasis on things that are like physics, math. It doesn't necessarily have to mean that they're true or accurate, but that they just go into detail about the... Oh, interesting. Like world building, as opposed to just like a light you know pulp fiction kind of thing taking place where gotcha ridiculous stuff happens and who cares like they they may break the rules but they try to be consistent with the rules once broken gotcha okay uh that's
科幻小说，但我并不觉得它是那种……等等，那是什么意思？我前几天还在查这个，什么是硬科幻，什么定义了硬科幻。我没能得出一个好的定义。但我认为它就是那种强调物理、数学等事物的科幻小说。它不一定非得意味着它们是真实或准确的，只是它们在……哦，有意思。就像世界观构建，而不是那种轻量级的、你知道的低俗小说，发生一些荒谬的事情，谁在乎呢？他们可能会打破规则，但一旦打破，他们会尽量保持规则的一致性，懂了，好的，那是
patrick's definition a lot of them i think do have do have rigorous worlds that they build. And like I said, they suspend disbelief, but then they keep it consistent. So things like Ringworld. Ringworld is not actually possible because it's this idea that you build a ring around a star and then people would live on the ring. But it wouldn't be stable because if the ring got got bumped it would kind of just like fall into the sun um i think anyways at least that's when i heard a talk by larry niven that's what he said so he's like ring world is not practical he had this other thing that was practical but ring world wasn't practical but oh i see like it made an attempt to try to say like oh it kind of makes sense that you would build a ring around the sun and everyone would live equidistant from the sun and then it would spin to you know keep gravity
帕特里克的定义。我想很多硬科幻作品确实有严谨的世界观构建。就像我说的，他们会暂停怀疑，但随后会保持一致。比如《环形世界》。《环形世界》实际上是不可能的，因为它的构想是在恒星周围建造一个环，然后人们住在环上。但它不会稳定，因为如果环受到撞击，它就会像掉进太阳里一样。嗯，我想反正至少当我听拉里·尼文的讲座时，他是这么说的。所以他说《环形世界》不切实际，他有另一个切合实际的东西，但《环形世界》不切实际。但我明白了，它试图说，哦，在太阳周围建造一个环，每个人都与太阳等距居住，然后它会旋转以保持重力，这在某种程度上是有道理的
and like anyways gotcha so so it takes something that isn't true but like formalizes it and builds the whole universe around it and you see sort of what that parallel universe would look like had that right so like stuff may try travel faster than light but then they'll impose some like arbitrary limit so that it's not like completely ridiculous it's just a little ridiculous oh okay uh anyways and so leviathan wakes is uh i i never know what to say without spoiling it so just check it out and read it it's a science fiction book about uh people in space in the kind of i would say more near future so people are kind of in the in the solar system versus going between the stars so and that way it's kind of different uh and uh this book is available on audible
反正就是这样。懂了，所以它采用了一些不真实的东西，但将其形式化，并围绕它构建了整个宇宙，你可以看到如果那个平行宇宙存在会是什么样子。所以，比如物体可能会尝试超光速旅行，但随后他们会施加一些任意的限制，这样它就不会显得完全荒谬，只是有点荒谬。哦，好的。反正，《利维坦觉醒》是……我从来不知道在不剧透的情况下该说什么，所以去看看并读一读吧。这是一本关于太空中的人们的科幻小说，我称之为更接近近未来，所以人们是在太阳系内，而不是在恒星之间穿梭。所以在这方面它有点不同。而且这本书在Audible上有售。
and if you've not checked out audible audible before you can go to audibletrial.com slash programmingthrowdown and get a free 30-day trial, which means you get a free book that you get to keep at the end, even if you don't continue your trial. You can get Leviathan Wakes, or you can get Godel Escher Bach. Oh, did you check? Is it available too? I made an assumption. They have, like, a lot of books.
如果你之前没有用过Audible，你可以去audibletrial.com/programmingthrowdown获取30天的免费试用，这意味着你可以得到一本免费的书，即使你在试用结束后不继续订阅，这本书也归你所有。你可以选《利维坦觉醒》，或者《哥德尔、艾舍尔、巴赫》。哦，你查了吗？它也有吗？我做了一个假设。他们有很多书。
I'm sure Godel Escher Bach is there, unless it's so hard to explain verbally.'t see it there so um oh okay never mind then yeah jason was just uh psyching you up for something that wasn't there but they do have lots and lots and lots of books so check it out they probably have at least something you'd be interested in listening to and getting for free with this trial or check them out on amazon or anywhere else as well i'm not supposed to say that am i oh well yeah it's fine um to to tool of the show so my tool of the show is not that useful but I think it's pretty cool it's called sell auto dot j s and it's a library for cellular automata so for people don't know I think we've covered it in the show but just in case you didn't catch that episode cellular automata just means you have some huge grid and you have some rule the rule can only take into account you know a cell
我敢肯定《哥德尔、艾舍尔、巴赫》在那里，除非它太难用语言解释了。没看到它在那里，所以……哦，好吧，那就算了。是的，杰森只是在为你推销一个不存在的东西，但他们确实有很多很多书，所以去看看吧。他们可能至少有你感兴趣听并可以通过这次试用免费获得的东西，或者去亚马逊或其他任何地方看看。我不应该那样说，对吧？哦，好吧，没关系。嗯，关于本期工具，我的工具不是那么有用，但我认为它很酷。它叫cell auto.js，是一个元胞自动机库。对于不知道的人，我想我们在节目中介绍过，但以防你没赶上那一集，元胞自动机意味着你有一个巨大的网格，并且你有一个规则，这个规则只能考虑到，你知道，一个单元
and its neighborhood but that rule is tessellated across the entire grid to make up a single epic or step so in other words the most common one is the game of life where the rule is if there's what is it like five to seven people are in your neighborhood so think about like a cell and and it's in 2d and so think about it like your phone your numeric pad on your phone and you're the number five and so you have you know eight numbers around you and uh if five to seven of those numbers are are true so we're thinking each of these numbers two to three oh it's two three like if each of these cells is holding like either holding life or not holding life so if two to three are holding life then you will if you're not alive that cell has no life in it it will flip and start having life if there's more or less if there's less
及其邻居，但该规则在整个网格上平铺，以构成一个单一的纪元或步骤。换句话说，最常见的是“生命游戏”，其规则是，如果有……是什么来着？比如有五到七个人在你的邻居里，所以想象一下一个单元，它是二维的，所以把它想象成你的手机，你手机上的数字键盘，你是数字5，所以你有八个数字在你周围。如果其中五到七个数字是真的，所以我们认为每个数字是二到三……哦，是二到三。如果每个单元格都持有生命或不持有生命，那么如果二到三个持有生命，那么如果你没有生命，那个单元格没有生命，它就会翻转并开始拥有生命。如果有更多或更少，如果有更少
and there's not enough to reproduce if there's more than saturated and your cell dies or if it was if there's nothing there it just stays in nothing so it's a very simple rule but because of the way it's tessellated across the whole grid and then that whole tessellation is applied over and over again across time, it creates these really cool looking animations and interesting dynamics that just keep you mesmerized. So that's the cellular automata. So what would be cooler than being able to watch that on the internet just by going to a website and not having to download anything? Anything on Netflix.
而且没有足够的数量来繁殖，如果有超过饱和，你的单元格就会死亡，或者如果那里什么都没有，它就保持什么都没有。所以这是一个非常简单的规则，但由于它在整个网格上平铺的方式，然后整个平铺在时间上被反复应用，它创造了这些看起来非常酷的动画和有趣的动态，让你着迷。这就是元胞自动机。那么，有什么比仅仅通过访问网站而无需下载任何东西就能在互联网上观看它更酷的呢？Netflix上的任何东西。
Yeah, right. Oh, no, no. I mean, nothing would be cooler than that. Nothing. Nothing. Wait. Netflix isn't in JavaScript. Oh, but it is on a website.
是的，没错。哦，不，不。我的意思是，没有什么比这更酷了。没有什么。没有什么。等等。Netflix不是用JavaScript写的。哦，但它是在网站上的。
That's true. Cell Auto is pretty cool. There's a bunch of different cellular automata, and so you can kind of play around with them. There's one that makes caves. They have one that has water that kind of like flows down as if it was. Oh, they do have the Game of Life. They actually have the Game of Life, which is pretty cool.
那是真的。Cell Auto非常酷。有很多不同的元胞自动机，所以你可以玩玩它们。有一个可以制造洞穴。他们有一个水，它会像那样流下来。哦，他们确实有“生命游戏”。他们实际上有“生命游戏”，这非常酷。
They have this one called Forest Fire. That's pretty cool. Oh, wow. There's one called Cyclic, which is some kind of like color cycling pattern. This is fascinating podcasting listening to Jason. Click through each one and tell us what it's doing. Why don't you give us a play-by-play on ESPN de Ocho? Oh, did I tell uh just random side note um i saw magic the gathering
他们有一个叫“森林大火”的。那非常酷。哦，哇。有一个叫“循环”的，是某种颜色循环模式。听杰森点击每一个并告诉我们它在做什么，这真是迷人的播客体验。你为什么不在ESPN de Ocho上给我们做现场解说呢？哦，我告诉过你吗……只是随口一提，我在一家运动酒吧看到了《万智牌》
tournament on espn at a sports bar the other day no and i thought what were you doing in a sports bar this is shocking wait go back i went to a sports bar to watch the stanley cup finals and the people sitting next to me were watching magic the gathering on espn i don't know infinity only in only in california and in san jose bay area felican valley yeah and i mean they were like really into it i mean at one point i didn't know that was actually a thing it's really on espn it was literally on espn i mean it was like just a highlight it was like literally the entire match was being filmed on espn and the announcers were very young i mean the announcers were maybe like 16 or something it was unbelievable um i learned
锦标赛在ESPN上播出。不。我想你在运动酒吧做什么？这太令人震惊了。等等，回去。我去运动酒吧看斯坦利杯决赛，坐在我旁边的人在ESPN上看《万智牌》。我不知道，无限，只在加利福尼亚，在圣何塞湾区，硅谷。是的，我的意思是他们真的很投入。我的意思是，有一次我不知道那竟然是一回事。它真的在ESPN上。它确实在ESPN上。我的意思是，它就像一个集锦，整场比赛都被拍下来在ESPN上播放，解说员非常年轻，我的意思是解说员可能只有16岁左右，这令人难以置信。嗯，我学到了
that as an announcer they train you not to say anything negative because these announcers would occasionally mess up because they were so young this announcer one time said um oh this one person messed up but then he went back and corrected himself and said oh no this other person was did this very well to cause the other person to do that so like i learned that that announcers always try to say just positive things anyways i feel like they i don't know i tried google searching magic the garan espn and it seems like they did at one time but i I tried Google searching Magic the Garen on ESPN, and it seems like they did it one time, but I can't find anything saying they were doing it recently. I know they do have the tournaments are broadcast,
作为一名解说员，他们训练你不要说任何负面的话，因为这些解说员偶尔会搞砸，因为他们太年轻了。这个解说员有一次说，哦，这个人搞砸了，但他回去纠正了自己，说，哦不，另一个人做得非常好，导致那个人那样做。所以我学到解说员总是尽量只说积极的事情。反正我觉得他们……我不知道，我试过谷歌搜索“万智牌 ESPN”，看起来他们确实做过一次，但我试过谷歌搜索“万智牌 ESPN”，看起来他们确实做过一次，但我找不到任何关于他们最近在做这件事的信息。我知道他们确实有锦标赛转播，
and people do watch them and announce them, and it's a big deal, but... I'm pretty sure it might have been another station. Maybe it was, like, MLG or something. Okay. I could have sworn it was, like, a big... Well, you keep looking for that, because I'm completely, like, maybe. They don't even show chess tournaments anymore, do they? lg or something okay i could have sworn it was like a big well you keep looking for that because
人们确实观看并解说它们，这是一件大事，但是……我敢肯定那可能是另一个频道。也许是MLG之类的。好的。我敢发誓那是一个很大的……好吧，你继续找那个，因为我完全……也许。他们甚至不再播放国际象棋锦标赛了，对吧？LG之类的。好的。我敢发誓那是一个很大的……好吧，你继续找那个，因为
i'm completely like maybe they don't even show chess tournaments anymore do they i've seen them on occasionally but i've never seen a chess tournament yeah on espn um i've seen spelling b on espn did you really once i think anyways all right that's amazing this is completely off topic my my tool of the show is a game for that's been out on many platforms called transistor uh recently came out for the ipad and so that's where i played it and so this is a game where uh you're a singer something has happened you befriend a sword that talks to you and helps you uh try to discover kind of what happened. And it is similar to Fallout and what you were describing, Jason, which is the only thing that I've heard before.
我完全……也许。他们甚至不再播放国际象棋锦标赛了，对吧？我偶尔见过，但我从来没见过国际象棋锦标赛。是的，在ESPN上。嗯，我在ESPN上见过拼字比赛。你真的见过吗？我想有一次。反正，好吧，这太神奇了。这完全跑题了。我的本期工具是一个已经在许多平台上发布的游戏，叫《晶体管》。最近在iPad上发布了，所以我就是在那里玩的。所以这是一个游戏，你是一个歌手，发生了一些事情，你与一把会说话的剑交朋友，它帮助你试图发现发生了什么。它类似于《辐射》和你描述的那种，杰森，这是我之前唯一听说过的。
It's like you can either play the battles out kind of in real time or you can push this button and then enter kind of like a turn-by-turn fight sequence. Okay. And your sword talks to you. It's like the narrator. Similar, it's by the same company uh that made bastion uh and so so there's a narrator that kind of talks to you and says what you're doing and then there's all these kind of like cool uh like side stories i guess in the game where you
就像你可以实时进行战斗，或者你可以按下这个按钮，然后进入一种回合制的战斗序列。好的。你的剑和你说话。它就像叙述者。相似，它是由制作《堡垒》的同一家公司制作的，所以有一个叙述者会和你说话，说你在做什么，然后游戏里有很多很酷的支线故事，我想，你在那里
like go up to a terminal and you know you can like vote in elections or like order pizza or like stuff that kind of has nothing to do with the game but kind of gives you the feel of what's going on in the world oh cool and so i'm not like this is the best game ever but i'm enjoying it so uh maybe when i finish i'll be like wow this is amazing um so i feel like it's interesting like there's a lot of games you know like the elder scrolls for example where they have they have books that you can actually read in-game, which have just a ton of lore and content in them. And I've never done that. But in Deus Ex, they had these computer terminals where you could log in, and they would kind of drop hints about the game, but they'd also have lore.
走到一个终端，你知道，你可以投票选举，或者点披萨，或者做一些与游戏无关但能让你感受到世界正在发生什么的事情。哦，酷。所以我不是说这是有史以来最好的游戏，但我很享受它。所以也许当我完成时，我会觉得哇，这太棒了。嗯，所以我觉得这很有趣，有很多游戏，比如《上古卷轴》，它们有你可以在游戏中阅读的书籍，里面有大量的传说和内容。我从来没做过。但在《杀出重围》中，他们有这些电脑终端，你可以登录，它们会提供关于游戏的提示，但也会有传说。
And those I would read, even if it was, you know, 20 pages or something. So it's like a fine line, but if you get it right, it's actually really cool as a gamer to sort of like just, you know, experience this lore if you're into reading. Yeah. Well, I feel bad because I kind of panned both my book of the show and tool of the show. I really did enjoy both.
那些我会读，即使它有20页左右。所以这就像一线之隔，但如果你做对了，作为一个玩家，如果你喜欢阅读，去体验这些传说实际上真的很酷。是的。好吧，我感到很糟糕，因为我把我的本期书籍和本期工具都批评了一番。我真的很喜欢这两个。
I am enjoying both of them. Well, I finished the book and I and tool of the show. I really did enjoy both. I am enjoying both of them. Um, well, I finished the book and playing through the game. I really didn't try. I just like, I need a caveat and not everything can be five stars. These are both like solid four stars.
我都很享受。好吧，我读完了那本书，还有本期工具。我真的很喜欢这两个。我都很享受。嗯，好吧，我读完了书，正在玩游戏。我真的没有尝试。我只是，我需要一个警告，不是所有东西都能得五星。这两个都是稳稳的四星。
Cool. Cool. All right. Time for our discussion of languages. Yes. So, uh, hopefully you had everyone out there had a rich childhood
酷。酷。好了，是时候讨论语言了。是的。所以，希望你们每个人都有一个丰富的童年
of uh messing around with something you know chemistry sets or um you know programming languages or what have you um patrick's you're actually at least a second generation computer scientist possibly more yeah if you include like mathematicians no my grandfather uh programmed on mainframes operating oh nice the third generation so my my dad is an engineer but my grandfather is a mathematician and so we have kind of geekery in our family too um and so yeah growing up like my cousins cousins and I would do a ton of this. It was just super entertaining. And I hope to one day, you know, my kid's very young, but I hope one day he will get into this too. So the reason we're having this is if you didn't get it from the title, we're going to talk about various programming languages targeting kids in a not creepy way.
玩弄一些东西，你知道，化学套装，或者编程语言，或者其他什么。帕特里克，你实际上至少是第二代计算机科学家，可能更多。是的，如果你算上数学家的话。不，我祖父在大型机上编程。哦，不错，第三代。所以我的父亲是工程师，但我祖父是数学家，所以我们的家庭也有极客基因。所以是的，从小到大，我和我的表兄弟们会做很多这种事。这超级有趣。我希望有一天，你知道，我的孩子还很小，但我希望有一天他也会喜欢这个。所以我们进行这次讨论的原因是，如果你没从标题中看出来，我们将讨论各种针对儿童的编程语言，以一种不令人毛骨悚然的方式。
Not that kind of targeting. So yeah, one of them is logo um i actually got introduced to logo through the delta drawing program that came out on atari but uh basically logo just i mean well i'm going to specifically talk about the turtle graphics part because i don't actually know anything about the rest of it patrick can probably fill in the holes here but there's a turtle graphics, turtle cursor part of logo. And it's pretty cool. Basically, you had a little arrow and you could give that arrow instructions like go forward but don't draw a line.
不是那种针对。所以是的，其中之一是Logo。我实际上是通过Atari上发布的Delta绘图程序接触到Logo的。但基本上Logo只是……我的意思是，好吧，我将专门谈论海龟绘图部分，因为我实际上对它的其余部分一无所知，帕特里克可能可以填补这里的空白。但Logo有一个海龟绘图、海龟光标部分。它非常酷。基本上，你有一个小箭头，你可以给那个箭头指令，比如向前走，但不要画线。
Go forward and, you know, leave a trail behind you or turn. And I think there are other things too. But basically, it sort of taught you to have this like psychocentric view where it's sort of like you had to, you know, if the cursor was pointed down, you had to understand that turning right kind of meant that it was the cursor's right, not your right. And so you had to kind of sort of like displace yourself and understand frames of references and things like that. So it's pretty cool. It was very useful even useful even i think like to build that mental capacity it was also extremely fun like i was able to draw the book came with a bunch of things for
向前走，你知道，在你身后留下痕迹，或者转弯。我想还有其他东西。但基本上，它教会了你拥有这种心理中心视角，就像你必须，你知道，如果光标指向下方，你必须明白向右转意味着是光标的右边，而不是你的右边。所以你必须有点像置换自己，理解参考系之类的东西。所以它非常酷。它非常有用，甚至我认为对于建立这种心理能力很有用。它也极其有趣，就像我能够画画，书里附带了一堆东西让你画，让你开始，然后从那里你可以把书里告诉你的东西拼凑在一起，做其他事情。比如我画了一个半马半猴之类的东西。你可以做各种各样的事情，比如有一个让你画一辆车，所以我能够画一堆车在高速公路上。真的非常有趣，强烈推荐。是的，我用的那个，我不记得确切是哪一个了，当然有海龟和绘图，但它还有其他的，你可以做一些更像……
you to draw to kind of get you started and then from there you could you either cobble together the things that it told you to draw to make other things like i drew like a half horse half you know monkey or something um you could you know do all sorts of stuff like there's one where i had you draw a car and so then i was able to draw a bunch of cars on a highway uh just incredibly fun and uh highly recommended yeah the one i used I don't remember exactly which one it had, of course the turtle and the drawing, but then it had other ones where you could do things like more like, uh,
蚂蚁之类的模拟，它们会留下信息素，然后其他的会跟随信息素。所以你可以模拟有食物和你的基地，蚂蚁会尝试去食物那里，然后回到基地，它们会留下信息素轨迹。然后它们会有点像，其他在给定方格里的更有可能移动到有信息素的方格里
ant kind of simulations where like they would leave pheromones and then other ones would, would follow the pheromones. So like you could simulate having food and like your home base and the ants would try to like go out to the food and come back to the home base and they would leave pheromone trails. And then they would kind of like, other ones in a given square were more likely to move into a square with the pheromones
而不是向随机方向移动。然后慢慢地它们会积累起来。所以它展示了这个基于代理的模拟，类似于杰森描述的元胞自动机，每个代理都在遵守同一套小规则，但在一起你得到了这种涌现行为，蚂蚁在屏幕上随机游荡，均匀地分布激素，但一旦一个找到食物，它就开始回家，并留下更直接的轨迹，然后另一个会这样做，另一个，另一个
than move in a random direction. And so then slowly they would kind of build up. And so then it was showing this agent-based simulation where similar to what Jason was describing with cellular automata, each agent is obeying the same set of small rules but then together you get this emergent behavior that their ants are randomly wandering around the screen distributing hormone evenly but then once one finds the food it starts to head back home and leaves a more directed trail and then another one will do it another one another
然后你知道，很快它们都往返于食物来源和基地之间。是的，是的，我记得我玩过那个游戏，我不记得名字或类似的东西，但它叫Mason之类的，但它超级有趣。是的，而且……我猜每个版本的Logo都不完全一样，没有一个标准。这是Logo语言，所以所有这些都添加了各种功能，然后它们通过使用新词来教如何制作函数。所以你可以最初说“向前90”，它会走90像素或什么，但如果你想说“画一个正方形”，它不知道什么是正方形，但你可以告诉它，让正方形成为以下步骤，这是一个函数参数，对吧？所以你可以开始建立你的语法
and then you know pretty soon they're all kind of going to and from the food source back to the home yeah yeah i remember that i played that same game i don't remember the name or anything like that but uh and so it's called mason or something but it's super fun yeah and um i i guess every version of logo isn't exactly the same there isn't you know one standard um this is the logo language so all of them have you know added various features uh and then you know they kind of teach fun making functions by using new words so you can initially say like ford 90 and it'll go for 90 pixels or whatever but if you want to say like draw a square won't know what a square is but you can tell it you know make a square be the following steps and here's a function parameter right and so you can kind of start to build up your grammar
函数，然后这就是孩子们开始引入这种非常图形化的方式，你知道，即使在我学习Basic之类的东西时，我总是想做的事情就是画东西，对吧？就像，只是画像素，即使是我在早期做C编程时，我做了命令行之类的东西，但我总是想能够只是画像素，像画移动的线条并填充它们。这对我来说非常困难，当我非常年轻的时候，因为在Basic里做这个很容易，但在C里，就像，不。是的，就像我从来没有过，直到今天，如果有人来找我，说“嘿，我想学C，我想用它来做非常基础的绘图，或者实现吃豆人之类的”，我不知道怎么告诉他们如何快速开始。是的，我不知道。我
of functions and then that's how like kids begin to introduce this very graphical way which you know is always even when i was learning uh basic and stuff like that was always the thing i wanted to do was like draw stuff right like yeah just draw pixels and even it was when i was doing c programming early on i did like you know the command line stuff but i always wanted to be able to just like draw pixels and like make lines that moved and fill them and it was actually hard for me when i was when i was very young because like in basic it was very easy to do that but in c it's like no yeah like i never had it still to this day if someone came to me and was like hey i want to learn c and i want to use it to just like do really basic drawing or like implement pac-man or something i don't know how to tell them like to get started quickly yeah i have no idea i
有同样的情况，我从用Basic制作游戏到……我们在这里有点跳跃了，因为我的意思是我们在Basic里制作游戏，我们当时大概10或12岁左右，但我从用Basic制作游戏到尝试用C构建一个MUD，或者只是编辑别人在C里运行的MUD。是的，是一样的情况，我只是……我的意思是控制台还可以，但尝试做任何图形化的东西几乎是不可能的。是的，所以我认为我会说，我想你会看到这些之间的一个共同主题，但我认为总的来说，图形部分对孩子来说真的很容易掌握，因为在某种程度上，它是非常直观的，出来的东西与仅仅是文本相比，文本有点无聊，就像你看到了什么，当它出错时，它看起来仍然很酷，就像“哦，它出错了”，但你有机会学到东西，对吧？因为你
had the same thing where i went from making games in basic to and we're kind of leaping ahead here because i mean we made games in basic we were i don't know 10 or 12 or something but i'm from making games in basic to trying to build a mud in c or just edit the mud um that someone else was running in c and yeah it was the same thing i was just i mean console was okay but trying to do anything graphical is just almost impossible yeah so i thought i'd say like i think you'll see a common theme among these but i think in general like the graphics part is really easy for kids to grasp because at some level you're it's very visceral like what's coming out as opposed to just text which is kind of boring like you're seeing something and when it goes wrong it still looks cool like oh it went wrong but you have the opportunity to learn something right because you
是的，看到发生了什么，然后想“哦，我没意识到会发生那样的事”，而不是仅仅崩溃，对吧？是的，我的意思是，崩溃就是崩溃，这几乎是不可能的。好吧，这并非不可能，除了语法错误之外，很难让这些东西崩溃。我的意思是，它们被设计成一种非常受限的动力系统，是的，你会让非常意想不到的事情发生，但你几乎总是会看到某种后果，而不是核心转储之类的东西。是的，所以我认为现在非常常见的是StarLogo。好的，他们刚刚发布了一个新的，有OpenGL图形，所以不仅仅是屏幕上无聊的2D调色板
yeah see what happened and be like oh i didn't realize that's what was going to happen versus just like crash right yeah i mean so the crash is a crash it's almost impossible well it's not impossible it's other than syntax errors it's very hard to crash one of these i mean they're kind of designed to be sort of a very constrained dynamical system and yeah you'll make very unintended things happen but but uh but you'll almost always see some kind of consequence not you know a core dump or something like that yeah so the really common one that i think now is star logo um okay and uh they just released a new one that has like open gl graphics so instead of just the boring like 2d uh palette on your screen
和移动海龟光标，你实际上有一个3D视图，你知道，更像Minecraft，我想。我不确定这是否增加了什么，但它就在那里。然后我找到了一个不错的教程TurtleAcademy.com，他们有一个Logo的网页版，所以他们既教你用Logo写代码，你也可以在他们的网站上交互式地运行示例，这非常酷。所以如果你有侄女或侄子，或者儿子或女儿，表亲，或者你自己正在听这个，那么你可以看看这个，它非常酷。我想我浏览这一堆东西时看到的一件事
and you know moving the turtle cursor around you actually have like a 3d view and you know more minecrafty i guess um i'm not sure that that adds anything but but it's there um and then i found a nice tutorial turtleacademy.com and they have a web version of logo so they both teach you to write code in logo and like you can run the examples interactively on their website so that's really cool so if you have like a niece or nephew or son or daughter cousin or somebody or yourself are listening to this then you can check this out and it's pretty cool I think the one thing that I saw when I was looking through a bunch of these one
一个我特别喜欢的共同主题是，它更具协作性，你可以让你的海龟画一些东西，然后发布到这个中央网站上。是的，其他人不仅可以看到你的画，还可以重新创建它，就像他们可以点击“开始”并观看海龟画你的车之类的。而且我认为整个协作部分非常酷，因为当我长大的时候，我的意思是，我确实做了高速公路上的车，实际上我记得特别清楚，我做了高速公路上的车，然后我去给父母看，当我回来时，我的一个表亲重置了Atari，它不见了。哦，太崩溃了。是的，
common theme that I was like especially fond of was that it's much more collaborative like you can actually have your turtle draw something and then post it to other to this central website yeah and other people can not only see your drawing but also recreate it like they could hit go and watch a turtle like you know draw your car or whatever um and i think the whole collaborative part is pretty cool because when i was growing up i mean i made that the cars on the highway actually i remember specifically i made cars on the highway and then i went to show my parents and when i'd come back um one of my cousins had reset the atari and it was gone i oh just so devastated yeah
我需要回去重新画那些车。你需要玩《最终幻想7》。这些东西中有一个与众不同。是的，但现在，我的意思是，你知道一切都是永久的。我相信这些很多就像谷歌文档，你知道你甚至不需要保存，它就在那里。但我怀疑……我敢打赌现在有人在Twitch上直播用Logo编程。是的，没错。而且它更具协作性，最终更有趣。
i need to go back and redraw those cars and you need to play final fantasy 7 um one of these things is not like the other yeah but now i mean you know everything is permanent um i'm sure these a lot of these are like google docs where you know you don't even have to save it's just there's but i wonder... I bet there are people Twitch streaming doing programming in Logo right now. Yeah, that's right. And it's much more collaborative and ultimately way more fun.
所以下一个特别大的是Scratch。所以Scratch在网上有一个非常大的社区。这是一个项目……很多这些都来自麻省理工学院。麻省理工学院在让……我猜是儿童友好的基于块的编程语言方面做了很多工作，而Scratch来自……不是为了跑题太多，但在50年代或60年代，当斯普特尼克卫星发射时，我想是50年代
So the next one is especially big in that Scratch. And so Scratch has a really big community online. And it was a project... A lot of these are out of MIT. MIT does a lot of work with getting I guess kid-friendly do we based programming languages and in scratch came from just not not to go too much on touch tangent but in this in there was the 50s or the 60s when Sputnik was launched I think is the 50s
政府资助了这个巨大的项目，这是一笔令人难以置信的钱，旨在让整个国家更多地投入到STEM中，人们不知道STEM是科学、技术、工程和医学、数学，哦，数学，抱歉。其中一个……所以这些拨款之一是关于教育的，并带来下一代数学家之类的东西。所以，你知道，其中一部分，很多都流向了麻省理工学院，这就是所有这些项目来源的地方。是的。所以Scratch与Logo不同。Logo是你程序的图形表示。
the government sponsored this gigantic program which is an unbelievable amount of money to get the whole nation more into stem and people don't know stem is science technology engineering and medicine math and oh math sorry and uh one of those uh and so one of these grants was all around education and bringing forth like the next generation of mathematicians and things like that. And so, you know, part of that, a lot of that went to MIT and that's sort of where all of these projects came from. Yep. So Scratch is different than Logo. Logo is a graphic representation of your program.
但Scratch，抱歉，你用文本编写，但结果是图形化的。在Scratch中，结果是图形化的，但你也以图形方式编程。所以用块和构建程序。而且真正酷的事情，我认为这也是引入编程的好方法，不仅仅是制作游戏，就像每个人都想制作游戏，这很好，而且有一种很好的Python方式来开始游戏，我猜叫Pygame，它工作得很好，但你知道，这很好，但制作游戏实际上很难，尤其是制作人们真正想玩的游戏，因为人们对游戏有很高的期望，他们期望能够进入菜单，开始游戏，有生命，或者
But Scratch, sorry, you write in text, but the results are graphical. In Scratch, the results are graphical, but you also program graphically. So with blocks and building up programs. And the really cool thing, which I think is also a great way to introduce programming is not just making games like everyone wants to make games and that's good and like there's a good python um a way to get started in games i guess pie game is what it's called um and it works really well but uh you know and that's good but making games is actually pretty hard like um especially making games people really want to play because people have very high expectations for games like they expect to be able to go to a menu and like start the game have lives or
你知道，死亡，或者进步，对吧？有危险，有风险，然后有一个游戏的结局，对吧？我的意思是，在你真正能称之为游戏之前，你必须做很多事情，对吧？完全正确。但Scratch被大量用于，我认为很棒的是动画。所以如果你想一想，你可以编程你的代码来运行一个演示，所以演示场景会很相似，用户输入不是真正必要的，它只是播放你编程的东西，但它仍然可以像游戏一样复杂，但你可以以一种更受控的方式构建它。你不必担心同样的事情。
you know die or like progress right have danger have risk and then like have an end to the game right like there's a lot of stuff you have to do before you kind of can really call it a game right exactly but what uh the scratches use a lot for and i think is is great is animation so if you think about it you can kind of program your code to just run through a demo so like demo scene would be similar where user input isn't really necessary it just plays out something that you've programmed but it could still be just as complicated as a game but you can kind of build it up in a way that's more controlled. You don't have to worry about some of the same things.
即使你只有一个简短的片段，人们也能理解。这就像一部短片之类的，对吧？是的，完全正确。我的意思是，游戏必须长时间吸引你的注意力，但动画可以和你想要的一样长，对吧？所以你知道，允许孩子们以编程语言风格构建小动画场景是引入这个概念的好方法，而不必担心人们做意想不到的事情，对吧？那是另一回事，学习它是好的，但一次只做一件事。是的，没错。所以Scratch支持两者，你可以制作游戏和使用输入，你可以产生声音，动画，甚至看起来有功能可以使用你的网络摄像头
And even when you just have a short snippet, people kind of get it. It's like a short movie or whatever, right? Yeah, exactly. I mean, a game has to hold your attention for a long time, but an animation can be just as long as you want it to be right and so you know allowing kids to kind of build little uh animated scenes in a programming language style is is a great way to introduce that concept and not have to worry about people doing unexpected things right that's a whole another thing that is good to learn but you know one thing at a time yeah right and so scratch supports both you can make games and use input um you can produce sounds the animations there's even it looks like a functionality to be able to use your uh webcam
作为输入。不太熟悉那个，但他们推广了很多用于编码俱乐部，我在学校里没有，但我简短地开始了一个，我相信很糟糕，但这没关系。但我们从来没有像编码俱乐部那样的东西，或者甚至像一个班级。所以让这个Scratch甚至给小学年龄的学生，所以孩子们，你知道，那会是七、八、九、十岁吗？十岁，我猜九、十岁，像三、四年级的孩子可以开始接触并开始掌握这些概念。所以你知道，如果你以前从未见过它，去看看吧。图形表示有助于你看到接下来应该发生什么，对吧？
as an input um not as familiar with that but um they promoted a lot for using in uh like coding clubs which i didn't have one in school but we had one briefly that i started which i'm sure was terrible but that's fine um but we never had like a coding club but i know it is a thing that people have or even like a class and so having this scratch for even like elementary age students so kids you know would that be like seven eight nine ten ten i guess nine ten uh like third fourth grade that those kind of age kids can begin to get started in this and kind of begin to grasp the concepts um and so you know if you've never seen it before check it out and the the graphical representation kind of helps you see what should come next right
所以当你输入一个for循环到C中时，不明显for行后面应该跟什么，或者哦，你需要花括号和中间的行之类的，对吧？这从“for”这个词本身并不明显，接下来会是一个循环。但当你有了这些图形化的东西时，循环块的结构实际上是这样的，你有点看到，哦，这个东西被包含在内，并且会反复运行。所以它也有助于你思考编程，我想，就像我们谈论了很多关于孩子和刚开始的人，但即使是我，我是这些人之一，我倾向于采取自下而上的方法，有时它会导致你实际上没有得到你想要的。你开始时想制作一个篮球视频游戏。
so like when you type a for loop into you know c it's not obvious what should follow the for line or that oh you need curly braces and the lines in between or whatever right like it's not immediately obvious just from the word for that the next thing is going to be a loop but when you have these graphical ones the structure of the block of a loop is actually such that you kind of see like oh this thing is contained and is going to run over and over again and so it helps you to think about programming i think too like when we were talking a lot about you know kind of kids and people who are just starting but even you know i'm one of these people i tend to be like kind of like take a bottom-up approach and sometimes it causes you to not actually get what you want like you started off wanting to make a basketball video game.
而你最终得到的是，你知道，百分之一的图形引擎。对。因为你只是在C语言中陷入了困境，以及如何打开窗口，如何画三角形。这需要，你知道，半年时间。是的，所以这种方式，你知道，从这样的东西开始，它强迫你，你知道，它是限制性的，但它也强迫你思考高层部分。如果因为你知道Scratch不允许你这样做，你无法让它看起来完全正确，那没关系，你知道，能够接受这一点对任何人来说都很有用。是的。
And what you end up with is, you know, one one hundredth of a graphics engine. Right. Because like you just got so bogged down in C and and how to open a window, how to draw a triangle. And that takes, you know, half a year and yeah so this way you know starting with something like this it forces you you know it's restrictive but it also forces you to think about the high level spot the high level part and if if you can't get it looking just right because you know the scratch won't let you it's fine and just you know being able to live with that is pretty useful for anybody. Yep.
所以下一个是乐高Mindstorms。这是每个孩子都想要的，但我从来没认识谁有这个。我也没有。有这些。但这看起来太酷了。每个人都知道乐高Mindstorms机器人可以解魔方
So the next one is Lego Mindstorms. This is the kind of thing that every kid wanted, but I never knew anyone who had this. I didn't either. Had these. But it looks so freaking cool. Everyone knows about the Lego Mindstorms robot that can solve the Rubik's Cube
这有多神奇。但是的，我从来没有过。哦，我一直喜欢赛格威的那种，那些可以自平衡的倒立摆。哦，是的，没错。所以是的，乐高Mindstorms是一个组合，正如你可能想象的那样，乐高和各种逻辑。它实际上有一个主块，有一个大的更大的块，本质上里面有一个处理器和一个小的LCD，那就是你加载代码的地方，然后你可以把传感器或电机插入那个集线器，从你的电脑下载你想在它上面运行的代码，然后你可以用乐高积木和这些执行器和传感器构建一个结构，一辆车，一个机器人，无论它是什么，一个魔方求解器
and how amazing that is um but yeah i never had one oh i always liked the segue ones the ones that like to self-balance the inverted pendulum oh yeah right right um so yeah lego mindstorms is a combination as you might imagine of lego and then various kind of like logic um is it actually there's a there's a main blocks there's like a big larger block that has essentially a processor in it and a little lcd and that's where you load your code and then you can plug in sensors or motors to that hub and um you know from your computer download the the code that you want to run on it and then you can build up a structure a car a robot whatever it may be a rubik's cube solver out of lego blocks with these actuators and sensors in
它们是如何实际连接传感器的？所以我猜你必须买一个非常具体的传感器，它们已经集成了，对吧？所以我相信它现在的工作方式实际上是I2C协议，所以人们现在破解其他传感器。哦，懂了。但是的，基本上有一个特殊的块，有一个传感器和一根线。然后集线器上有一个特殊的连接器，你把那个块插进去。懂了，懂了。但是的，基本上它与那个东西进行I2C通信。
them how do you actually connect the sensor so i guess you have to buy a very specific sensor where they have integrated right so i think i believe the way it works now is actually an i squared c protocol so people hack in other sensors now. Oh, got it. But yeah, basically there's a special block that has a sensor and a wire. And then a special connector on the hub that you plug that block into. Gotcha, gotcha. But yeah, basically it talks I2C to that thing.
而且他们只有一小套他们支持的传感器。好吧，小是相对的，我想。但这个东西的酷之处在于，他们当然有一个由LabVIEW支持的图形编程语言，我可能……我们也许可以做一个关于LabVIEW的完整节目，但LabVIEW是National Instruments公司的一种图形编程工具，它本身就是一种图形编程工具，而且更针对，我猜你会称之为严肃编程。但他们有一个版本，它支持这个NXTG，用于编程乐高Mindstorms。而酷的地方在于，你正在以图形方式编程，就像你在Scratch或Logo中看到你的GUI一样，在这里你实际上看到现实世界中的东西在移动，现实世界中的输入影响它。所以我认为这是另一个让人们保持参与的伟大刺激源。是的，是的，这太神奇了。我想知道你真的能做……我猜没有什么能阻止你，对吧？制作一辆小车之类的。不，不。我的意思是，它有电池吗？是的，是的，所以它有电池，它会四处走动。你可以制作循迹机器人。酷，酷。所以还有很多替代语言涌现出来，令人惊讶的是有多少，就像我去了维基百科查看有多少，我想说至少有十二个。所以你可以用C编码，你可以用任何Visual Basic编码。
And they just have like a small set of sensors they support. Well, small is relative i guess um but the cool thing about this one is that they have of course a graphical programming language backed by labview which i've maybe we might could do a whole show on labview but labview is a graphical programming uh thing all of its own by national instruments uh and is more targeted to like i guess what you would call even serious programming um but they have a version it backs this nxtg which is used to program lego mindstorms and the cool thing there is like you're programming graphically and just uh like you would see your gui and scratch or logo here you actually see something in real world move and inputs in
有这个RoboMind，它也有一个模拟部分。所以你实际上可以模拟你的机器人在模拟世界中四处走动。所以你可以用像真正的编程语言一样写，当你准备好时，你可以从这些……我不会称它们为玩具，酷。所以它就像一座桥梁。是的，所以你开始只是做视觉化的，但你没有我们那样的经历，没有巨大的鸿沟，就像你的整个宇宙分崩离析。是的，所以我正在读……Zed Shaw，一个写了《笨办法学Python》的Python人，正在谈论这个。他说他为初学者编写了《笨办法学Python》，人们不
the real world affect it and so i think that's yet another like great stimulation source for keeping people engaged yeah yeah it's amazing i wonder can you actually make i guess there's nothing stopping you right from making like a little car or something like that no no i mean does it have a battery yeah yeah so it has a battery and it'll move around you can make line following robots yeah cool cool and so then there's a lot of alternative languages that sprung up and it's actually surprising how many there are like i went on wikipedia to look at how many there were and there's like i want to say at least a dozen um so like you can code it in c you can code it in like any like visual basic the uh
现实世界会影响它，所以我认为这是让人们保持参与的另一个很好的刺激来源。是的，这太棒了。我想知道你是否真的可以制作，我想没有什么能阻止你制作一辆小车之类的东西。不，我的意思是它有电池吗？是的，它有电池，它会四处移动，你可以制作循迹机器人。太酷了，所以后来涌现了很多替代语言，令人惊讶的是数量竟然这么多。我上维基百科查了一下有多少种，我想说至少有十几种。你可以用 C 语言编写，也可以用像 Visual Basic 这样的语言编写。
there's this robo mind which uh has a simulation part to it as well so you can actually like simulate your robot moving around in a simulated world um and uh so you can write in like even like real programming languages when you're ready you can step to it from kind of these uh i won't call them toy cool so it's like a bridge yeah so you start off just doing visual but then you don't have the experience we had where you there's not a huge divide to see and it's just like your whole universe falls apart yeah so i was reading um and zed shaw a guy in python who wrote python the hard way um was talking about this he was saying like he wrote python the hard way for beginner programmers and people don't
还有一种叫 RoboMind 的东西，它也有模拟部分，所以你实际上可以模拟你的机器人在模拟世界中移动。当你准备好时，你甚至可以用真正的编程语言来编写，你可以从这些我不会称之为玩具的东西过渡到真正的编程。所以它就像一座桥梁。是的，你一开始只是做可视化编程，但你不会像我们那样经历巨大的鸿沟，导致整个世界观崩塌。我当时在读 Zed Shaw 的文章，他是《笨办法学 Python》的作者，他谈到了这一点。他说他为初学者编写了《笨办法学 Python》，而人们并不
understand what beginner programmers mean they think it means like people who already do a lot of maybe like shell scripting or something uh want to learn programming or people who've done a lot of like excel and maybe did a little bit of dabbling with macros he's like no no no people who like you can't tell them type the pipe character. They don't know what the pipe character is. You know, they don't know like how you would even like get into manipulating files, like opening an editor, typing a file in, saving it to somewhere known in the directory structure, opening a command line, getting to that folder. Right. Like that whole process would be foreign to these people. Like those are the people that, you know know we're really going to have to help we can't just expect the only people who are worthy to learn programming are people who already know their way around a computer uh to a high degree um i never really thought about it yeah like i guess i have a pretty high bar for where i would expect people to start before they
理解初学者程序员的意思，他们认为这意味着像那些已经做了很多 shell 脚本之类工作的人，或者想学习编程的人，或者那些经常使用 Excel 并稍微接触过宏的人。他说不不不，那些人你甚至不能告诉他们输入管道字符。他们不知道什么是管道字符。你知道，他们甚至不知道如何操作文件，比如打开编辑器、输入文件、保存到目录结构中已知的位置、打开命令行、进入该文件夹。对吧。整个过程对这些人来说都是陌生的。这些人才是我们真正需要帮助的对象，我们不能仅仅认为只有那些已经非常精通计算机的人才配学习编程。我以前从未真正考虑过这一点，是的，我想我对人们在开始学习编程之前应该具备的水平设定了很高的门槛。
learn programming yeah i i have the same thing i mean i guess the issue is you know we grew up in the dos era where if you wanted to use a computer you had to learn that and so it by you know the because of that it became a prerequisite it's like you couldn't program if you couldn't use a computer and you couldn't use a computer if you couldn't do dos and dir and pipe and all those things but most people didn't want to use a computer when that's all it could do. Yeah, right, right. So that's why we have sort of the skewed view.
学习编程。是的，我有同样的感觉。我的意思是，我想问题在于我们是在 DOS 时代长大的，如果你想使用计算机，就必须学习那些东西。因此，它成了先决条件。就像如果你不会使用计算机就无法编程，而如果你不会使用 DOS、dir、管道和所有这些东西，你就无法使用计算机。但大多数人并不想在计算机只能做这些事情的时候使用它。是的，没错。所以这就是为什么我们有这种扭曲的观点。
It's interesting. So I think these two we're talking about are great introductions. And you have some others. Yeah, so I use this one a ton. It's called AuthorWare. Apparently it was bought by Macromedia, which was bought by Adobeobe and so it was called adobe author where uh much later but i used it when i was in high school or maybe even
这很有趣。所以我认为我们谈论的这两个是很好的入门介绍。你还有其他的吗？是的，我经常使用这个。它叫 AuthorWare。显然它被 Macromedia 收购了，后来又被 Adobe 收购，所以很久以后它被称为 Adobe AuthorWare，但我是在高中甚至可能是
middle school it came with my packard bell so um it's pretty cool um basically it was this flow chart based uh model where um think about kind of like Flash, but the user experience is a little bit different. So as you do in Flash, you have objects on the screen. You would animate them by dragging them around, things like that. You could listen to user events. But instead of having sort of that timeline in Flash, which
初中时使用的，它随我的 Packard Bell 电脑一起提供。所以它非常酷，基本上它是一个基于流程图的模型，你可以把它想象成 Flash，但用户体验有点不同。就像在 Flash 中一样，屏幕上有对象。你可以通过拖动它们来制作动画，诸如此类。你可以监听用户事件。但它没有 Flash 中那种时间轴，
has all these objects that exist, you know, in time, and exist in different states across time, things like that. In this case, it was all flow based. So there'd be some root node that would get executed. And then there'd be a node that says, you know, draw a car. And that node would have a child node that says, wait four seconds, then it would have a child node that says wait four seconds then it would have a child node saying you know move the car so on and so forth and then because you could have a many-to-one relationship you could say okay once the car has moved then do these 10 other things so you can imagine how it's kind of like a tree structure um but yeah i built a bunch of animations in it
它拥有所有存在于时间中的对象，并且在不同时间点处于不同状态。在这种情况下，一切都是基于流程的。所以会有一个根节点被执行。然后会有一个节点说，画一辆车。那个节点会有一个子节点说，等待四秒，然后它会有一个子节点说等待四秒，然后它会有一个子节点说移动汽车，以此类推。而且因为你可以拥有多对一的关系，你可以说，一旦汽车移动了，就执行这 10 件其他事情。所以你可以想象它有点像树状结构，但我确实用它制作了很多动画
and stuff like that it was super fun apparently it It was super fun. Apparently, it's discontinued. Of course. Yeah, so it got discontinued in 2003 or something. So you can't use that. But you can use Adobe Flash, which is a very similar idea and arguably better in almost every way. And Adobe Flash is a great way to get into programming because you start off just animating by you know literally just taking things you drew in Microsoft Paint or or or GIMP or what have you Photoshop dragging them into
之类的东西，非常有趣。显然它已经停产了。当然。是的，它在 2003 年左右停产了。所以你不能使用它。但你可以使用 Adobe Flash，这是一个非常相似的想法，而且在几乎所有方面都可能更好。Adobe Flash 是进入编程领域的好方法，因为你一开始只是通过字面意思，把你用 Microsoft Paint、GIMP 或 Photoshop 画的东西拖到
flash and then just moving around in time and then adjusting the scene how you want it at various points in time and then adjusting the scene how you want it at various points in time and i have this animation then you start you can learn about action script and and you gracefully go from you know pure visual environment to writing code so adobe flash is pretty awesome definitely check it out if you haven't already i've never used flash before i i don't know why yeah wow really um i mean i've used it so i've used flash before that was poorly stated i've never like written or authored any flash anything yeah you've never used flash studio yeah um yeah that's uh yeah i don't uh oh you know i think because i have a minor in digital media so for me I had to take a bunch of
Flash 中，然后在时间轴上移动它们，并在不同时间点调整场景，然后你就有了一个动画。接着你可以开始学习 ActionScript，并优雅地从纯视觉环境过渡到编写代码。所以 Adobe Flash 非常棒，如果你还没用过，一定要试试。我以前从没用过 Flash，我不知道为什么。哇，真的吗？我的意思是，我用过它，所以我以前用过 Flash，刚才说得不对。我从来没有编写或创作过任何 Flash 内容。你从来没用过 Flash Studio？是的，我想是因为我辅修了数字媒体，所以我必须参加很多
classes where we were forced to use flash um so but yeah if you take any like intro to digital media or anything uh well maybe now it's different but at the time they would teach you they would definitely teach you flash I wonder sort of what is replacing HTML5
强制使用 Flash 的课程。所以，如果你参加任何数字媒体入门课程，也许现在情况不同了，但在当时，他们肯定会教你 Flash。我想知道什么在取代 HTML5
HTML5 obviously is replacing the technology but what's replacing Flash Studio? In other words, if I wanted to take someone who doesn't know anything about programming and get them into what I just... Recreate what I just described, what would I use? No idea.
HTML5 显然正在取代这项技术，但什么在取代 Flash Studio？换句话说，如果我想找一个完全不懂编程的人，让他们进入我刚才描述的领域，我该用什么？不知道。
Put it out to the audience. I think actually Adobe has... You're not going to put it to the audience. Adobe Flash has an HTML5 exporter or something, but I don't know you're gonna put it to the audience has an html5 exporter or something but i don't know yeah we'll ask the audience if you are an adobe flash wizard um let us know sort of what the next step is i'm really curious i mean i i believe adobe can export to html5 now but i'm not 100 i don't even know really kind of what that means because i'm sure they're not just completely
向观众提问。我想其实 Adobe 有……你不会向观众提问的。Adobe Flash 有一个 HTML5 导出器之类的东西，但我不知道……你会向观众提问，它有一个 HTML5 导出器之类的东西，但我不知道。是的，我们会问观众，如果你是 Adobe Flash 大师，请告诉我们下一步该怎么做。我真的很好奇。我的意思是，我相信 Adobe 现在可以导出到 HTML5，但我不是 100% 确定。我甚至不知道那意味着什么，因为我肯定他们不是完全
compatible. Let us know. I'm curious. Alright. We got one more? Oh, just real quick. We have a Wikipedia link on our... We'll put it on the website, which has a list of
兼容的。告诉我们。我很好奇。好的。还有一个吗？哦，很快说一下。我们在我们的网站上有一个维基百科链接，上面有一个列表，列出了
educational programming languages. If you have a son or daughter, or if you uh want to uh you know look at a uh one of these kind of beginner languages i think it's really fun to to do that and and create some cool stuff uh check out our link it has a ton of languages way more than we could cover yep and if you're too if you're too leet for all of these, then try one of our other podcasts. Yeah. So the FeedBurner, last time we talked, we were, I think it was like 200 people away from 10,000. We are now 140 people away from 10,000.
教育编程语言。如果你有儿子或女儿，或者如果你想看看这些初学者语言中的一种，我认为做这些事情并创造一些很酷的东西真的很有趣。看看我们的链接，它有很多语言，远比我们能涵盖的多。是的，如果你觉得这些太简单了，那就试试我们的其他播客。是的。关于 FeedBurner，上次我们交谈时，我想我们离 10,000 人还差 200 人。我们现在离 10,000 人还差 140 人。
We only gained 60 people in a month I know right I know welcome to 60 more of you this is your second episode yeah welcome you 60 people to the show and everything super awesome
我们一个月只增加了 60 人。我知道，我知道。欢迎这 60 位新朋友，这是你们的第二集。是的，欢迎你们 60 人来到节目，一切都太棒了。
either way man we're super grateful for having such an appreciative audience one thing that I kind of struggle with and i'd be interested to your feedback is you know we have twitter people reply on twitter and retweet and ask us questions on twitter people ask us questions on facebook and uh there's communications going on google plus and i really feel like we should kind of bring this together. It's kind of silly that there's just like three separate discussions happening at the same time. So I don't really know what to do about that. If anyone there has any suggestions, post your suggestion all three times.
不管怎样，我们非常感谢拥有如此欣赏我们的观众。有一件事我有点纠结，我很想听听你的反馈，你知道我们在 Twitter 上有人回复、转发并向我们提问，人们在 Facebook 上向我们提问，而且 Google Plus 上也有交流，我真的觉得我们应该把这些整合在一起。在同一时间发生三个独立的讨论有点傻。所以我真的不知道该怎么办。如果有人有什么建议，请把你的建议发三次。
I'm a social hermit, so you can mail me a letter and uh i may respond to you oh man but yeah i mean i'm really curious sort of you know anyone out there even if you have a small company that you run or something like that like how do you solve this problem where you know we have a lot of followers but when you split it three ways um it just uh it doesn't build enough of a core base. Yeah. It sort of dilutes everything like, like exponentially. Like I think if we could get everyone on one platform, it would be,
我是个社交隐士，所以你可以给我写信，我可能会回复你。哦天哪，但我真的很好奇，外面有没有人，即使你经营一家小公司之类的，你是如何解决这个问题的？你知道我们有很多粉丝，但当你把它分成三份时，它就无法建立足够的核心基础。是的。它有点像指数级地稀释了一切。我想如果我们能把每个人都集中在一个平台上，那会是
it would be really special. There would be dozens of us. That's right. Oh man. So, uh, uh, yeah.
非常特别的。会有几十个人。没错。哦天哪。所以，是的。
So anyways, we really appreciate your support and, uh, thanks a lot for watching the show, listening to the show. Until next time. Yep. see you later distribute, transmit the work, to remix, adapt the work, but you must provide attribution to Patrick and I and share alike in kind. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
总之，我们非常感谢你们的支持，非常感谢观看和收听我们的节目。下次见。是的，再见。分发、传播作品、重新混合、改编作品，但你必须注明 Patrick 和我的署名，并以相同方式共享。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。